the notion of talking with
self-transforming machine elves which is
how I put it in my book the invisible
landscape seemed I mean I couldn't
believe it when I wrote these words on
paper it seemed like such a freaky
notion but people say you know yes
that's it I know what you're talking
about I saw that same thing too well
that seems to me to mean that self
transforming machine elves is actually a
a step forward in language and that the
psychedelic issue is somehow linked to
the evolution of language and that we
are not and in fact the whole culture
crisis generally is linked to a direct
evolution of language we have to change
the way we speak about reality and then
it will be perceived as different and
this apparently cannot be done by great
leaps it's done incrementally by
introducing a concept here a word there
a notion somewhere else but the
psychédélices ation if you will of
society and language seems to me was
never blunted and goes on a pace and has
ever since Leary and Metzner and all
those giants back in the Stone Age
dumped LSD on American society I see it
everywhere in InDesign in music in
fashion everywhere that doesn't count
someone said to me it's everywhere but
in the control mechanism but I think the
control mechanism is probably the last
to get the news the culture is shedding
its skin faster than anyone can
anticipate so this evolution of language
thing really interests me and recently
when people have been saying you know
what do you want to do with it where do
you want to take it I'm less interested
than I used to be in extraterrestrials
flying saucers all of that stuff I still
access it regularly
but you see when I first started
publicly speaking I thought that that if
people confirmed what I was saying the
obligation would somehow leave me to do
anything about it and it would be like
NASA would take care of it or something
like but I've discovered that you know
as my friend Erika Yohn used to tell me
that society really is metastable but
you know I'm perfectly free to say these
outlandish things and you're perfectly
free to believe them and to say them to
your friends and it doesn't matter a bit
apparently so
or or the effect is so long-term that it
doesn't matter a bit so I've turned from
the question of indicating the presence
of the other to the question of what is
it like to be the person who indicates
the presence of the other and so I'm
more interested in the the
transformation of the quality of daily
experience when we are unstoned or at
least unstoned enough to be here without
any of us making any of the rest of us
uncomfortable and I think that there are
bridges that can be built out of the
psilocybin experience into ordinary
reality and how this is to be done I
think is through the transformation of
language and somehow the recognition of
emotion it took me a very long time to
figure out that emotion comes in more
than 40 acres
you know I was very I had thoughts
running through my mind all the time and
I also had this undercurrent of
something else which was highly variant
and ever-changing which I finally
figured out that is emotion and the
nature of emotion is it son English
ability I mean you can say you know I
love her I hate her this and that but
you never come in to the depth of the
modality of this present but unlined
whadja bull
background in which we're embedded and
this is what I think that the psilocybin
allows it allows some kind of bridge
from that uh nimble background of being
into language so that you can begin to
articulate articulate
you
[Music]